you know if you go out in the streets
anywhere in america these days you won't
see a lot of people out shopping because
of the covet restrictions but
going at home you see a lot of this
going on people going into their
iphones or or their their imacs or
whatever they happen to be shopping with
and uh and buying stuff online
this is this a sign of the times times
square would be shoulder to shoulder
in the weekend after thanksgiving in any
other year
because of the covet restrictions look
at it now it's very very sparsely
populated
but online shopping was so busy this
year there was a 22 percent
increase from last year's online
shopping that's huge
that's a record nine billion dollars for
black friday alone
uh so we will be following that those
sales figures but a huge increase in
online
shopping not surprising considering the
lockdowns and how much
everybody's shopping from indoors and
remember there's a record number of
savings
burning a hole in the pockets of a lot
of consumers out there
they're allowing some of that money to
get out through online sales i just
bought a tv yesterday so i was part of
it all